[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
kochwelt ich mache heute wieder eine
leckere suppe und zwar gibt es bei uns
heute eine kartoffelsuppe also eine crew
wäre so und bei mir geht es später ein
paar dampfnudeln mit dazu und ich zeige
euch einfach mal ganz kurz die zutaten
bis ich übrigens eine suppe also ich hab
so mit den jahren
ich bin noch nicht so alt aber mit den
jahren habe ich einfach so mein
lieblings kartoffelsuppe rezept so
entwickelt und ich bei mir kommt da
immer ein bisschen noch anderes gemüse
mit rein und das war also ich habe zu
viel kartoffeln das sind mehlig kochende
kartoffeln und wenn sie geschält sind
sollten es 700 gramm sein und dann
brauchen wir eine große zwiebel hier ein
paar champignons ich habe jetzt hier 250
gramm
aber man kann zum beispiel auch direkt
die doppelte menge nehmen also ich nehme
auch 250 gramm wenn ich zb die hälfte
der kartoffel habe deswegen egal wie
viele hier habe ich 50 gramm butter
hier habe ich zwei starken
staudensellerie das ist richtig intensiv
im geschmack vor allen dingen ganz
wichtig für die suppe und dann einfach
noch ein paar gewürze als wenn das salz
pfeffer muskatnuss finde ich immer ganz
lecker und chili und thymian und gleich
brauche ich noch ein bisschen wasser
zuerst einmal muss ich jetzt mein gemüse
stehen also die zwiebeln und die
kartoffel wartet das mache ich gleich
ich muss erst sehen
[Musik]
erkannt dass man sagt man aber wie das
richtig geht
[Musik]
nein erst oben ja der fahrer kann das
geld war mit mama kommen mit sei es papa
und zack zack und die so geht es so ja
wenn du zeit hast
ich kann jetzt wo ihm eine zwiebel und
würfeln und zwar mache ich das jetzt
hier wieder mit dem schneidegerät aber
wenn ihr das nur messer macht einfach
kleine würfel als schatz ich muss sie
erschienen und jetzt gebe ich schon mal
die butter in einem topf ich nehme jetzt
dafür einen ziemlich großen topf denn es
wird gleich ziemlich viel suppe ich kann
die butter jetzt auch gleich schon mal
verlassen
aber ich warte noch kurz denn ich muss
erst die kartoffeln schälen fuchs kam
ich mach das
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt hier meine mutter bereits
bei niedriger stufe zu lassen und jetzt
gebe ich die zwiebelwürfel mit dazu ihr
könnt natürlich auch olivenöl benutzen
aber ich bin sehr guter geschmack ist
auch nicht lecker im olivenöl im kann
man das ganze nicht vegan machen mit saß
ich die hier bei mittlerer stufe etwas
raten genau jetzt bereiten wir schon mal
die kartoffeln und beschäftigen uns zwar
schneide ich die kartoffeln auch in ganz
kleine würfel und zwar samira genau ganz
vorsichtig wartet finger so ein bisschen
was ich mache dir einmal bot man kanzler
stellen jetzt so scheiben schneiden
wie überhaupt die finger auf acht geben
was macht den daumen weg ja so also ich
schneide ist einfach erst mal in
scheiben und dann kann ich das da drin
nämlich auch würfeln
[Musik]
mein gemüse ist vorbereitet und hier
drinnen riecht einfach nur lecker weil
ich finde die kombination aus butter und
zwiebeln ist einfach sehr lecker und
jetzt gebe ich einfach meine restlichen
zutaten dazu also mein gemüse der hero
die kartoffeln und die samira darf
kräftig rührt dann kann ich das machen
aber nicht die champignons und auch
seiner dem sellerie oder die hälfte
nehmen kräftig durchrühren das geht
richtig schwer
und dann ließ sich das ganze jetzt mit
zwei litern wasser auf also ich habe
zuerst mal 1 meter und dann gebe ich
gleich noch mal dazu
das ist aufkochen und dann darf das
einfach mal so 15 20 25 minuten lang
kochen ist einfach die kartoffeln gar
sind ja auch interessant
[Musik]
meine suppe ist jetzt gekocht und ich
werde jetzt einmal parieren aber nicht
komplett als ich da schon das sind
stückchen drin bleiben
[Musik]
jetzt wird sich die suppe noch mit salz
und pfeffer und mit meinen anderen
gewürzen
so müsste einfach nach eigenem geschmack
aber ich finde frische muskatnuss muss
bei einer kartoffelsuppe immer mit dazu
chilli sowieso bei uns ein bisschen
damit diesem jahr auch gleich mit ist
ein bisschen thymian für den geschmack
wer übrigens den sellerie nicht so gerne
stück ich in seiner suppe hat kam auch
den sellerie so als stange reingeben
dann verliert er seinen geschmack geht
alles in die suppe ja du dachtest machen
und dann kann man ihnen einfach vor dem
pürieren rausnehmen und hat praktisch
nur noch selten nur noch champignons und
kartoffeln mit drin
es geht diesen schwierig weil wir haben
nämlich fast keine pfefferkörner
leiterin nicht mehr danach
[Musik]
meine suppe ist jetzt fertig habe es
jetzt auch bereits abgespeckt und was
geht bei der super noch machen könnt wer
möchte kann zum beispiel noch ein paar
bisschen klein schneiden rhein geben die
geben den ganzen auch noch mal so
richtig würzigen geschmack oder ihr
könnt auch am anfang karotten mit
reingeben andere gewürze benutzen also
alles so wie ihr das gerne möchte
wer will kann zum beispiel auch so ein
bisschen sauerrahm noch mit dazu geben
da hat man noch so ein bisschen was
cremiges und wir probieren die superzahl
zusammen
ich gebe ja gucken wir mal
[Musik]
natürlich noch sehr heiß wieso auch
probiert würde ich war ein bisschen zu
schlafen aber wir machen einfach bei ihr
noch ein bisschen sauerrahm rein
das nimmt ein bisschen die schärfe und
ich finde das ist eine richtig schöne
cremige suppen ohne dass ich jetzt da
nimmt drin habe und auch sehr wichtig
und ich muss noch ein bisschen salz mit
reingeben märkte grad hat immer noch ein
bisschen gefehlt aber sehr lecker vor
allem mit den champignons die mag ich
nämlich sehr gerne bei übrigens nur bis
farbe wird rein will kann zum beispiel
am ende noch für klein gehackte rote
paprika mit dazugeben sieht nämlich auch
richtig hübsch aus oder zum beispiel
erbsen kann man noch mit rein geben oder
ihr könnt mir immer schreiben was ihr so
bei euch in eurer kartoffelsuppe gerne
habt was er damit rein gibt und mein
rezept gibt es auf meinem blog auf und
wir warten jetzt noch auf unsere
dampfnudel und dann essen gleich alles
will er bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]